When someone knocks at his door wdcpd
policeman Hank Greeley is having the
time of his life in a hotel room with a
Russian hooker he opens the door to see
two police officers standing outside his
door Greely is not interested in small
talk but the men barge in claiming they
must ask him something Greely throws a
tantrum threatening to have the officers
fired and claiming they cannot harass or
enter his room without a signed warrant
unfortunately his Outburst only amuses
the men it turns out that the two men
Jimmy Bobo and his partner and best
friend Luis Blanchard are hitmen hired
to kill Greely Luis shoots Greeley but
Greely flees and retaliates he jumps on
Louise and starts beating him managing
to grab the gun before he can kill Luis
Jimmy intervenes with a fatal shot to
the Head Jimmy hears some whimpering
coming from the bathroom and finds the
Russian hooker he's about to kill her
but relents when he sees the tattoo of a
cougar on her back he lets the hooker
Lola go ascertaining that she will keep
silent about what has happened later
Jimmy and Louise go to a bar to
celebrate their kill not noticing
another Hitman silently observing them
as the night progresses Jimmy excuses
himself to use the restroom Luis is
still drinking when someone accidentally
spills a drink on him before he can
react the Hitman stabs him severely
leaving him dead he walks to the
bathroom and starts assaulting the
unsuspecting Jimmy luckily Jimmy quickly
defends himself resulting in a fierce
Fight The Hitman leaves after failing to
kill Jimmy while Jimmy Mourns the loss
of his partner wdcpd Detective Taylor
Kwan arrives in New Orleans to
investigate Hank really's death it turns
out that the two were Partners but had a
falling out that resulted in Hank being
disgracefully discharged Quan learns
from Lieutenant leberton that Lola has
confirmed Greeley's assassination he
also learns about a second body brought
in later that night Kwan visits the
morgue where Louise's body is being held
he quickly discovers that Louise had
something to do with Greeley's death he
also feels that the two murders are
connected but does not understand how
yet Juan manages to trace Louise's
information on the police database
Fortune Luis has been known to associate
with Jane's bonomo AKA Jimmy Bobo Kwan
finds out all he can about Jimmy and
arranges to meet him at a pub he often
hangs out at Quan tells Jimmy that he
knows about his occupation as a Hitman
and his last case however he reveals
that he is not interested in bringing
Jimmy in for Greeley's murder instead he
wants the two to work together and find
out who did the hiring as the same
person who is responsible for Louise's
death Jimmy contemplates the offer for a
few minutes before blatantly refusing as
he does not work with cops Jimmy leaves
the pub and Quan follows him to the
parking lot unfortunately Kwan is
attacked by two corrupt cops who want
him to stop investigating Greeley's
death Quan is shot in the shoulder but
before much harm can be done Quan
manages to disarm One Cop and gun down
the other luckily Jimmy hints the other
cop with his car and grabs Quan he takes
him to a tattoo parlor where a beautiful
woman Lisa treats Kwan's wound Lisa is a
former med student so she retrieves the
bullet in men's Kwan's shoulder after
they leave leave The Parlor Quan teases
Jimmy about Lisa wondering what Jimmy
gives her to keep her loyal he makes fun
of Jimmy's personality claiming that no
woman can love him for it Quan quickly
shuts his mouth when he learns that Lisa
is Jimmy's estranged daughter the two
have been at odds as Jimmy was never a
present father when Lisa was growing up
Jimmy is a retired veteran meanwhile the
other Hitman Keegan meets up with his
boss who turns out to be Robert Morrell
a local land developer Morel has some
shady dealings which is lawyer Marcus
Baptiste covers up Marcus reveals that
Greeley had tried to Blackmail morale
since he had a file containing morel's
illegal operations unfortunately Riley
had left the file with local monster
baby Jack Marcus wants Keegan to
retrieve the file and kill anyone who
knows what it contains Keegan quickly
visits baby Jack's gang Hideout he
viciously kills all the gang members and
leaves one alive so he can open the safe
Keegan quickly retrieves the needed file
and proceeds to kill the other gang
members leaving behind a trail of death
and destruction Jimmy and Quan visit
another massage parlor where they
interrogate Ronnie Earl as he was the
man that hired Louise and Jimmy to kill
Greely Ronnie confesses that he had
hired the two on morel's behalf and
knows nothing about the later
assassination of Luis or the attempt on
Jimmy Ronnie slyley tries to kill Jimmy
but Jimmy quickly defends himself and
kills the man first later Jimmy argues
with Quan as he finds that Quan has
jammed his gun this would have cost him
his life earlier Jimmy will work with
Quan on the condition that he
understands that they are on two
different sides while Quan wants to
arrest the gang members and bring them
to justice Jimmy has stayed in the town
long enough to know that all hands can
be greased and the easiest way to stay
alive is by killing your enemy Jimmy
wants Quan to do his job but he has to
let Jimmy do his as well Quan agrees to
the terms and the two find out more
about Morel and Marcus they realize that
Marcus will host a costume party that
evening and they decide to crash it
Jimmy and Kwan locate Marcus and kidnap
him after knocking him out they take him
him to Jimmy's house and restrain him on
the chair interrogating him when he
wakes up Marcus who has no sense of
loyalty for anyone but himself quickly
starts talking Keegan is an ex-mercenary
who has had his missions worldwide
including in central Africa and Lebanon
Marcus is pretty confident that Keegan
will find him and kill the two so he
continues talking he reveals that
Greeley's bribery file contained
information about morale's payoffs to
various senators and Congress members as
well as his development plans to
fraudulate the city he plans to acquire
housing projects in the crime filled
Estates and demolish them to build
Office Buildings this will give him a
Sleek profit Jimmy takes an interest in
Marcus's necklace he opens it to find a
flash drive Marcus has a record of morel
Shady dealings which he gives as
leverage Marcus continues blabbering
which annoys Jimmy who shoots him in the
head Quan is agitated by this but has
little time to act as Keegan and his men
have managed to locate Marcus's phone
signal to the apartment another gunfight
ensues with Keegan and his men shooting
anyone in their way after a series of
gunshots are fired in the apartment Kwan
and Jimmy managed to escape they
detonate a bomb in the apartment which
kills most of Keegan's men Jimmy's
demeanor has changed and he wants
revenge against the men behind his
misery coincidentally something snaps
inside Keegan and he badly wants Jimmy's
blood however Quan is tired of Jimmy's
barbarism and disregard for human life
he decides to solve the case on his own
and leaves Jimmy to get revenge as he
intends Quan reaches out to Lieutenant
leberton hoping that he will Aid his
mission however Quan is in for a rude
surprise when the lieutenant tries to
kill him as he is also on morel's
payroll luckily Jimmy has followed Quan
so he saves the ladder and kills the
lieutenant he cautions Quan to be
careful as he cannot trust anyone
blindly Jimmy might be a professional
killer but at least he goes for those he
has a vendetta with meanwhile Keegan
looks into Jimmy and learns about his
daughter Lisa he has his men kidnap Lisa
and calls Jimmy intending to trade Lisa
for the flash drive Jimmy agrees to the
terms and meets with Keegan at an
abandoned warehouse Jimmy meets up with
Keegan some henchmen and Morel in the
warehouse Morel might be a shady
businessman but he is not as ruthless a
criminal as Keegan this is why he agrees
to let Jimmy and Lisa go after he gets
the flash drive this action profoundly
angers Keegan who is out of her blood
after seeing Jimmy kill many of his men
Morel slightly remarks that he let Jimmy
go as he has leverage while Keegan on
the other hand does not Keegan quickly
turns on his boss and kills him and his
men before going after Jimmy he wants
hand-to-hand combat with Jimmy so he
retrieves some fire exes and gives Jimmy
one a serious fight ensues with both
parties enduring deep wounds luckily
Jimmy manages to stamp Keegan in his
throat this is not enough to take the
giant down Jimmy is about to give up
when Kwan shoots Keegan dead from afar
Quan had infiltrated the building
earlier and started taking out Keegan's
men he also grabs the flash drive
finally he shoots shoots Quan in the
shoulder so that it appears that Quan
has failed to arrest him Jimmy also
advises Quan to let him take the credit
for all the murders including the ones
that Kwan had committed Jimmy wants to
leave but Lisa decides to stay back and
keep Quan alive while they wait for the
police officers to show up Jimmy is at a
bar when Kwan meets him he reveals that
he never mentioned Jimmy's involvement
in the murders to his superiors however
he wants Jimmy to straighten his act as
he cannot always cover for him Jimmy
slyly asks Quan to try and arrest him
before walking away
[Music]